Let's take a closer look at these two plots. Now, it
might be hard to determine which gender has more friends on
average. Remember, that's the question
we're investigating. Who has more friends,
males or females? So, instead of looking at these histograms, we
can use the table command to see if there are more
men versus women. When I run that command, I get this
output. So, it looks like there's slightly more males than females
in our sample. To look at the average friend count by gender,
we'll need another new command. This command is the 'by'
command. The 'by' command takes three inputs: a variable, a categorical
variable, or a list of indices to subset over, and
a function. In our case, we want to use the Summary
as the function to get basic statistics on our friend
count. So, friend count's the variable, gender is our categorical variable,
or the variable that contains our segments of users. And,
we want a summary of the friend count by gender. Now,
I'm not going to run this code, but I want you
to run it in RStudio and then answer these next questions.